Here's an example of how it all works.
This I've actually typed into the Python interpreter.
I've defined a function f as a lambda expression. It looks like this.
Then I've asked what F is.
All Python prints out is it says that it's an object of type function,
which doesn't have a name other than the lambda
and the address and memory where it's stored.
Then I'd say, is F true of the sequence 1, 2, 3, 4, 5.
That is, Y is equal to 1, M is 2, E is 3, U is 4, and O is 5.
The answer is no, it's False. This is not equal.
Then I asked is it true for 2, 1, 7, 9, 8. Yes, that's true.
The reason is because it works out to this expression 289 equals 17-squared.
Now I'm thinking of a design where we have some type of a solve function
that's going to solve a formula, and we're going to have a compile formula function
that's going to take a string formula as input and return a lambda expression function
as the result of compiling the formula.
As part of that, I want to have a function that I'm going to call compile_word,
It's going to take a word like ME and compile that into something like 10M plus E.
You could have some variation on exactly how you want to express that.
It will also take a word like equals and compile that into itself,
into equals, and a word like 2 and compile that into 2 itself.
This is the function I want you to write.
Compile_word where compile_word of YOU is something like this--
don't worry about the communicativity and associativity.
You can write this any way you want as long as it is a code that would compute the right answer.
It's important to put parentheses around it.
Anything that's not an uppercase word you should leave alone.